let's just play the intro well here's
another [ __ ] tweet from meet press
supply change disrupted labor unrest
take a toll labor unrest what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
labor unrest
no it's not labor un unrest labor is
winning
that's what's happening that's why
everyone's so pissed off that's why
[ __ ] the the businesses are pissed
off the capitalists are pissed off is
because labor's winning
what don't you people understand about
help wanted signs everywhere is a
workers economy that's what's pissing
them off is that oh my god we have to
compete for their labor this is [ __ ]
they have to compete they've had they've
never in the last three decades really
four they've never had to compete for
labor they haven't they haven't had to
compete for it
they've never had a situation where
people like ah i'd rather not work than
work for that amount that sucks
that's horrible [ __ ] you that won't buy
me [ __ ] i would rather not have money
than not have the little pittance that
you are giving me [ __ ] you i can make it
without money a lot better than i can
with money because it'll cost me more to
work
than it will not to have money negative
money negative money
is a lot less than no money you get it
right do you get that you get that
people negative money
is a lot less than no money you get it
when a person has
children for example
and you have to get two [ __ ] jobs to
survive right
you have to do something those children
go somewhere
someone you have to pay someone for
their labor to watch and take care of
your children got it
that's one problem that we have
the other problem that we have is people
figured out people figured out that you
you can do things to live off one job
especially when you get to pick the job
you have you get to pick it there's all
kinds of help wanted signs everywhere
you can pick any job you want [ __ ]
there's jobs everywhere there's help
wanted signs everywhere don't you
[ __ ] get it
that help wanted signs in all the
[ __ ] stores and all the [ __ ]
businesses is a sign that it's a workers
economy
got it it's a workers economy so let's
listen to what [ __ ]
chuck todd
has to say in his opening
about [ __ ] jobs in the economy
because he gets it totally wrong here
and i'll
bury him in an economic story
let's listen to this
and a good sunday morning the economy's
inability to fully recover from the
shock of cover 19 is both an economic
story and a political one
so what is holding the economy back in
the spring we thought we were turning
the corner on covet but when we turned
that corner the delta variant was
waiting on the other side to hit us hard
in the face delta and vaccine refusals
sent cases to their second highest peak
of this pandemic this summer before they
finally began to trend downward let's
hope
so here is chuck todd explaining that
coronavirus and
and virus and disease in general can
affect the economy here he is
explaining it showing a graph explaining
that disease and virus and a pandemic
can [ __ ] affect the economy and we
all know this and if you haven't figured
out that disease and a pandemic can
affect the economy
were you [ __ ] asleep last year were
you [ __ ] asleep so let's
let's continue on to what kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] he spends at the end
man out there a postcoded supply chain
backup has spread across the globe
causing so here we go post covid so he's
saying oh
well coronavirus ran rampant but now
we're all of a sudden because boats are
offshore it's post covered it's post
what is it chuck are we still are we
still in covid are we not
stupid [ __ ]
cargo ship traffic jams slowing delivery
of goods
and yes driving up costs in fact those
higher costs have helped feed a rise in
prices all over the map leading to the
sharpest rise in inflation in 13 years
on top of that hundreds of americans
have decided
here we go look at look look look at the
background he has
now hiring
now hiring so chuck todd's gonna make
the case here the right wing case the
the case that the [ __ ] republicans
these [ __ ] the [ __ ] fascists are
making
that oh
having hi now hiring signs everywhere is
a bad sign of the economy for who for
the for the people running the
businesses well that tough [ __ ] [ __ ]
then compete for our labor
it's it's amazing to me that capitalists
in this country self-proclaimed
capitalists because they're not really
[ __ ] capitalist a cap a real [ __ ]
capitalist understands that in a
capitalist [ __ ]
economic system when you have to compete
for people's money
when you have to market to compete for
people's money you also have to might
have to compete for people's [ __ ]
labor
they have to compete for our labor
that's part of [ __ ] capitalism we
don't have to just give them our [ __ ]
labor that is not a thing we have to do
they have to compete for it they have to
trade something to us for our labor
just like we trade them money for their
[ __ ] products and their [ __ ]
services
when in the [ __ ] did we go to sleep on
this
when the [ __ ] did this country take a
nap on on
people negotiating their [ __ ] labor
and trading their labor
when did we [ __ ] take a nap on this
they have to compete for our
labor we are trading our labor for part
of their profits that's how it [ __ ]
works
and we took a [ __ ] we took a long
[ __ ] four decade nap on this stupid
[ __ ] and we still haven't woke up from
it chuck todd you [ __ ] idiot listen
to this buffoon
they don't want to return to their old
high stress
low wage jobs
so that's keeping job creation
stubbornly low who gives a [ __ ] if job
creation is low
us filling shitty positions is not job
creation that's all [ __ ] that's all
talking points from the right wing
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we get to [ __ ] decide how much we
trade our labor for and they have to
[ __ ] compete for it that is how this
[ __ ] works
look at the sign he's got behind him
here now hiring sign on bonus
so we're hiring wherever the [ __ ] this
place is
and we will hire you and we want to hire
you so much that we will give you a
sign-on bonus that's called competition
that's called competing that's called
capitalism when they are [ __ ]
competing for your [ __ ] labor
why do you why do you think everywhere
it the minimum wage really doesn't even
mean [ __ ] right now
it doesn't even mean [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] stupid
low that
everyone's competing way above the
minimum wage
way above it
way above it
that's why it needs to be raised so they
have to compete even higher
we should force them to compete for our
labor
got it
[ __ ] chuck todd for the last two
months and take some important workers
out of the supply chain
all those economics oh
so the private sector supply chain
doesn't get to have the labor because
they won't pay what those [ __ ] people
are demanding they won't compete for
that labor to keep their supply chains
open so that they could continue to sell
us [ __ ] from china are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
what why is that bad why is that bad
that is not a bad thing for workers in
the long run sure sure in the next few
months six months eight months or so it
might it might sting a little bit but
that is not bad for workers and honestly
here's the secret it's not bad for
business either
you don't see the stock market tanking
do you nope
you don't see investors bailing out of
investment do you
nope
the reason why is because there is
inflation
and guess what has to be done with wages
when that happens the wages have to
inflate you dumb bastards
that's why you have to compete for our
labor so compete so compete
do it
good luck problems add up to a big
political problem for the president is
all of this his fault of course not and
this is the other [ __ ] dumb argument
from chuck todd here is that somehow
somehow a worker's economy
an economy where a person
a person doesn't have to stand for the
the only job that is available in their
area that there's plenty of jobs
available in their area that they can
actually have some [ __ ] ability to
choose which [ __ ] job and which
[ __ ] wage they want because
businesses in their area are competing
for their labor
that somehow that's bad for joe biden
that a worker's economy this is this is
why the media is completely [ __ ] all
[ __ ] up here they are completely all
[ __ ] up they they are completely
believing this right-wing propaganda
[ __ ] that a worker's economy is a
bad economy that's not it might be bad
for some people
but it's going to get better for the
workers are you [ __ ] paying attention
but it is now his responsibility and he
and fellow democrats are in real danger
of suffering some serious political
consequences mr biden ran out of promise
of a basic return to normal or at least
a path to normalcy but with the midterm
elections just over a year away
unless voters see evidence
oh my god here we are we were in a
global pandemic
where millions of people lost their jobs
and over 700 000 people have died we
can't even convince morons
that that want to return to normal to go
get vaccinated and somehow the return to
normalcy isn't fast enough as if as if
biden had some sort of [ __ ] magic
wand
no one voted for biden because they
thought he had a magic wand that's not
what happened
nobody voted for biden because they
thought he had a magic wand
81 million people didn't actually vote
for joe biden a lot of those people did
but most people voted against donald
trump you get it right they voted
against him they didn't want that
[ __ ] we did that [ __ ] for four
years and we definitely seen how he
handled the pandemic not just the
[ __ ] virus itself but the economy to
boot
we watched it we experienced it
we knew what road that was headed down
so americans took their [ __ ] bet on
not donald trump
not a magic wand not some [ __ ] wizard
joe biden is no [ __ ] wizard but i'll
tell you what he has done
he has made it to where he
workers have a workers economy
he's done that i mean if you have to
give him credit if you have to give him
credit for everything else gas prices
inflation blame everything on biting
right oh
empty shelves biden or whatever the
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] was this week's
trending on [ __ ] twitter about
the the [ __ ] bare shells biting or
some [ __ ] as if we didn't have bare
shells left almost all last year and you
couldn't you couldn't even buy two bags
of meat you couldn't buy certain meat
you couldn't get [ __ ] toilet paper
last year and we're and we're [ __ ]
talking about bear shells biting what
the [ __ ] are you people talking about
you can go in any store and get
500 different
kinds of snickers bars
and you're worried about [ __ ] bear
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here you people
and your fake [ __ ] outrage your fake
[ __ ] outrage it's the same [ __ ]
fake outrage that chuck todd has here
about businesses having helped wanted
signs in their [ __ ] windows who the
[ __ ] is pissed off i tell you what who's
not pissed off about all the help wanted
signs workers workers people who [ __ ]
work for a living who pay [ __ ] taxes
that give you the give you [ __ ] rich
people all your goddamn production and
all your profit where do you think it
comes from
where do you think all your profit comes
from you have to trade for production of
labor you [ __ ]
so compete for it [ __ ] chuck todd
this
i i i am i i have not went off on chuck
todd yet but it is about time for me to
[ __ ] go off on chuck todd it's
goddamn about time to [ __ ] eviscerate
this son of a [ __ ] and and nbc and meet
the press really need to think real hard
about what kind of [ __ ] they're pushing
what kind of [ __ ] lies they're
propagating out there
hope wanted signs are not a sign of a
bad economy i mean they may be bad for
some but a very [ __ ] few small slim
people
so chuck todd
and meet the press need to check it
of this new normal this you decide to
return power
back to the record
[ __ ] idiot
and i and and chuck todd oh the economy
is going to be bad so people are going
to are going to vote for for whoever's
not biden what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
what are you talking about it the
economy that we have right now with help
wanted signs everywhere is good for many
not for little you boneheads
the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here okay so
i do want to play the clip of